ce
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce premier
numéro de la saison du 7-8 en direct
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi entre 18
heures et 19 heures nous ferons le point
sur l'actualité et du département des
journalistes reviendront bientôt sur ce
plateau également pour vous éclairer sur
toute l'actualité locale des invités
également puisque c'est la rentrée nous
avons convié sur ce plateau des
fédérations de parents d'élèves et tout
d'abord la fcpe
bonsoir à vous merci pierre fraude est
revenu pour commenter un petit peu
l'actualité de cette rentrée êtes vous
serein est ce que la fcpe tout se passe
bien on n'est pas serein non non on sait
pas on attend encore un petit peu la
rentrée de demain pour l'instant n'a pas
beaucoup d'informations mais on n'est
pas serein on va développer ça justement
avec vous également ce 3 septembre
sommaire du 7-8 un point complet sur les
jeux paralympiques de londres des
athlètes yvelinois y participent
elle nous entendrons leur entraîneur
dans une vingtaine de minutes se met
pour l'instant voici les titres de ce 3
septembre en images françois hollande
était en visite à trappes le président
de la république est venu saluer les
initiatives de l'établissement situé en
zone d'éducation prioritaire est
présenté à ses ambitions pour l'école
elle de nouveaux professeurs stagiaires
affectés dans le département pendant une
semaine ils ont suivi un stage au lycée
de launay de villepreux nous le verrons
tout à l'heure à la faculté de médecine
de saint quentin en yvelines qui ouvre
ses portes au 856 étudiants de première
année témoignage à suivre dans ce set 8
et puis les agences de notation de notre
pas que les pays elles peuvent aussi
évaluer la politique financière et d'une
commune deux agents sont accordés à la
note a+ à la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin prenez
et pour débuter cette première édition
de la saison c'est donc la préparation
de la rentrée des classes qui va nous
occuper durant les prochaines minutes
c'est notre fait du jour et ce matin
françois hollande je vous le disais
était à trappes dans les yvelines à la
rencontre des enseignants du collège
youri-gagarine et cette phrase prononcée
alors de son discours chaque rentrée
scolaire est un véritable défi il a par
la suite insisté je fais de la jeunesse
et donc de l'école la grande priorité de
mon mandat à pierre fraude au président
de la fcpe 78 quelle est votre réaction
vous vous disiez inquiète au début de
cette émission
lorsque vous entendez le président dira
que la priorité ce sera l'éducation
l'école la jeunesse ça vous rassure un
petit peu ça nous rassure un petit peu
ça nous rassure pas plus que ça ce que
l'on attend nous ce sont des actes pour
l'instant on est dans la politique on
est dans le déclaratif
on est dans la consultation on n'est pas
encore dans les actes et ce qu'on attend
ce sont des actes qui est mille postes a
tout de même mis en place dès l'élection
françois hollande oui aller à l'échelle
nationale la chaîne mais à l'échelle
nationale à l'échelle des états unis ça
ça ça on fait quoi 200 et à l'échelle du
département encore beaucoup moins et on
sait que les le manque est énorme donc
voilà c'est une goutte d'eau dans un
océan mais bon une goutte d'eau c'est
mieux que rien disait les choses doivent
se mettre en place également là en fait
c'est pas là pas vraiment la première
rentrée de vincent peillon c'est plutôt
la sixième rentrée de l'ancien ministre
luc châtel exactement exactement c'est
la dernière rentrée de monsieur chatel
on est très contents mais on attend la
prochaine rentrée donc l'année prochaine
en espérant que cette année 2012 2013 va
pas se passer trop mal on va voir
comment c'est passé justement cette
visite de françois hollande ce matin au
collège youri-gagarine de trappes
catherine gélato patrick jacques de
dixmude étaient sur place tu regardais
françois hollande le président de la
république en déplacement à trappes ce
lundi pour présenter sa refondation de
l'école il a d'abord discuté avec des
enseignants du collège gagarine
il a d'ailleurs salué les outils
d'innovation mises en place comme
l'expérience de l'accueil des enfants de
l'école élémentaire avant leur entrée au
collège
ce que vous avez fait ici à trappes nous
devons le faire partout où il est
possible d'engager cette politique
l'objectif c'est que les enfants sortant
du primaire accèdent au second degré
avec des connaissances suffisantes
c'est en effet une piste extrêmement
intéressante parce que les enseignants
se connaissent lieu partagent davantage
la la même culture professionnels
réfléchissent ensemble sur les
progressions pédagogie sur l'accueil des
élèves
je pense que c'est un des éléments
d'explication important des résultats
très prometteurs de l'établissement le
secret il est la fopac et truc tu
rentres premier degré second degré et si
le socle commun est déjà bien installé à
la sortie du cycle 3 et des écoles on
pourra que mieux accompagner les élèves
vers le lycée
dans son discours le président a rappelé
que l'école était la grande priorité de
son mandat
plus de professeurs avec l'ouverture de
22 mille postes aux concours externes de
2013 dont 6000 en contrat d'avenir
le rétablissement de la formation
initiale pour les enseignants il a
également confirmé l' annonce faite
dimanche par vincent peillon
il y aura bien des cours de morale
laïque dispensé de l'école élémentaire à
la terminale
on va avoir le définir dans la
commission qui va se mettre en place
mais c'est tout ce qui relève pas
seulement de l'instruction civique c'est
à dire connaître les lois le
fonctionnement démocratique mais en même
temps réfléchir sur le sens de la vie
sur la justice sur les devoirs à l'égard
de soi même et à l'égard des autres des
anneaux
jugé par les enseignants pensent que
c'est bien de remettre des enseignants
dans les classes
ce que ça maintenant il en manquait
après les suppressions et malgré les
mille enseignants supplémentaires à la
rentrée je crois que il ya treize mille
suppressions de postes donc ça j'espère
que ça va être une évolution et je pense
qu'il faut généralement plus d'adultes
dans les collèges
mise à part les enseignants évidemment
mais tous les personnels de direction
des cpe les assistants d'éducation
les postes les postes des gens qui
partent qu'ils vont être remplacés ça
c'est génial la formation parce que
c'est vrai que ces jeunes qui arrivent
c'est vrai que les gènes ont besoin
d'une formation où débarquent pas comme
ça ici comme ça la concertation
concernant l'école devrait prendre fin
au mois d'octobre pour la présentation
devant l'assemblée nationale d'une loi
d'orientation sur l'éducation d'ici à la
fin de l'année toujours en direct si
vous nous suivez sur tv fil entre 18 et
19 heures nous faisons le point sur
cette visite de françois hollande au
collège youri gagarine attrapé puis
cette annonce vous l'avez entendu dans
ce reportage
la morale laïque vincent peillon en
avait parlé elle serait mise en place à
la rentrée 2013 du côté des parents
d'élèves
est-ce qu'on accueille favorablement
cette cette mesure de mise en place de
morale laïque ça irait au delà de
l'instruction civique ans selon vincent
p oui alors ça reste quand même encore
un petit peu un petit peu sibyllin com
com on trouve toujours des jolies
formules il faut voir ce qui ce qu'on
entend par morale laïque c'est quand
même philosophie qu'on peut à ce qu'il
ya une morale des morales s'il ya une
morale laïque et de morale qu'est pas
laïque donc plusieurs moral est-ce que
vous pensez que les anciens résidants
ont besoin aussi la voir ce genre de
cadre d'apprendre justement la morale
tout simplement les règles je pense je
pense que ça peut être ça peut être
important c'est important il faut voir
comment ça va être fait voir si les
enseignants vont être formés pour
enseigner cette morale voilà cc c'est
uniquement une question de formation des
enseignants et mais autrement oui ça me
semble aller plutôt une bonne sans qu'il
n'y a pas que la question d'amour alain
qui va occuper forcément l'éducation
nationale cette année il ya beaucoup de
dossiers importants on va en parler on
va les détails et dans un instant
notamment avec la fcpe
auparavant lors de cette visite de
françois hollande vous vous en doutez
benoît hamon élu député de la 11e
circonscription qui couvre la commune de
trappes était forcément sur place il a
fait le déplacement il a été nommé
ministre de françois hollande catherine
flattot elle a rencontré pour faire le
point sur les différentes annonces de ce
matin françois hollande le président de
la république est venu ce matin au
collège gagarine de trappes il est venu
saluer les expérimentations menées dans
cet établissement notamment le lien qui
est fait entre l'école élémentaire et le
collège
il a également annoncé la poursuite de
la refonte de l'école plus de postes le
retour de la morale laïque de l'est que
de l'école élémentaire à la terminale
le rétablissement de la formation
initiale pour les enseignants et pour en
parler avec nous benoît hamon il a été
élu député de la circonscription de
trappes et l'encours en juin dernier
il est ministre de l'économie sociale et
solidaire est important qu'ils viennent
dans un établissement qui a
particulièrement travaillé la passerelle
entre le primaire et le secondaire
notamment en sixième avec des
enseignants du primaire qui viennent
jusque
au collège et qui travaillait que leurs
collègues du secondaire pour faciliter
cette transition et permettent notamment
de faire face à un ensemble de
difficultés d'apprentissage qui sont
celles d'élèves de 6e qui maîtrise mal
le français
il a aussi dit que cette expérimentation
elle pourrait être étendue à l'ensemble
de la france dans l'établissement en
tout cas où ce serait possible vous
voyez le but de ce qui sera l'ambition
éducative du gouvernement entre les
moyens supplémentaires qui vont être
donnés surtout à partir de l'année
prochaine puisque cette rentrée nous ne
l'avons pas pas préparés nous mêmes et à
travers la loi d'orientation sur
l'éducation nationale ce sera justement
de refonder le contrat éducatif de
généraliser des expérimentations qui
marche plutôt que de venir les visiter
comme on l'a fait aujourd'hui constater
que ça marche ici mais que ça marche pas
ailleurs et de permettre
justement que aujourd'hui on lutte
contre les inégalités que produit le
système éducatif qui trie tron encore
les élèves par l'échec
ça va mettre du temps pour ça qu'il
faudra refonder le contrat éducatif et
c'est pour ça aussi que la république de
renseigner ses valeurs c'est tout le
sens de l'enseignement de la morale
laïque qui sera fait du première jeudi
jusque jusqu'en terminale
c'est un peu les cours d'éducation
civique qu'on a connu oui mais c'est
plus que ça c'est de dire quelle est la
communauté de destin qui lie celles et
ceux qui vivent dans la république
quelle que soit leur origine quelle que
soit leur âge quelle que soit leur foi
ou leur absence de foi quelle que soit
leur condition sociale il rappeler ce
qu'est le projet républicain lui
redonner du sens le renvoyer à des
réalités vécues par les jeunes c'est
mieux que d'en parler comme ça de
manière incantatoire où tout le monde
évoque la république manière un peu
messianique comme ça sans pour autant
que un enfant qu'ils aillent à l'école
de la république sache véritablement ce
que c'est la république
en quoi ça a du sens pour lui
d'apprendre d'apprendre des autres et
c'est tout la tâche de la république
d'assurer l'égalité des citoyens et puis
permettent à chacun d'apprendre
s'émanciper de s'épanouir voilà il a
annoncé aussi le retour à la formation
initiale l'ouverture de 22 mille postes
aux concours externes en 2013
les ambitions oui bon on va avoir plus
de profs on va avoir des
pré-recrutements pour permettre à des
jeunes en l2 qui ne se seraient pas
destinés au métier de professeur de
pouvoir le faire en leur permettant au
delà de leurs bourses de disposer d'un
revenu supplémentaire
aux emplois d'avenir pour pouvoir
justement préparer à les concours voilà
on veut qu'ils aient davantage de profs
que le recrutement de ces profs soient
plus divers qui est pas en clair que des
gens qui ont les moyens de se payer des
études à bac + 5 qui soit prof
aujourd'hui c'est toute l'ambition de ce
gouvernement
benoît hamon ce matin aux côtés de
françois hollande à trappes pour cette
visite présidentielle pour la pré
rentrée ce sera demain jour de rentrée
il ya beaucoup de dossiers qui vont être
discutés dans les prochains jours dans
les prochains mois et tout d'abord du
côté de la fcpe vous avez choisi
d'emmener en tout cas votre président
national a choisi d'emmener un petit peu
la discussion sur l'évaluation des
élèves
le président a parlé du côté de la fcpe
de supprimer les notes jusqu'au collège
oui oui c'est inception de notes plus
les nôtres c'est un thème c'est vrai qui
est cher à aux prises on accepte et à
l'ensemble des départs en live c'est
peut enfin l'ensemble des parents a
beaucoup de parents fcpe
c'est vrai que les notes où il ya
d'autres moyens d'évaluer les élèves
l'évaluation est important bien sûr
alors qu'en fait il ya d'autres moyens
mais si vous voulez y ont le problème
c'est que la note on elle-même sèche ne
veut rien dire puisque on sait quand on
a 13 on aurait pu avoir 16 ou on aurait
pu avoir 10 il vaut mieux noté la
progression d'un élève qu une note qui
correspond sur un devoir à un classement
finalement par rapport au reste de la
classe ça s'appelle marché sont de la
philosophie on va dire où c'est plus
subjectif sur la natte son nez sur des
mathématiques sur des choses très exact
ce qui compte c'est l'évolution de
l'élève en fait le problème c'est plutôt
comment est-ce qu'un élève et évolue
plutôt que quel est son niveau
finalement et c'est vrai que bâle sur
des sur les mathématiques bien sûr mais
pourquoi pas les mathématiques aïe aïe
il ya d'autres choses que le résultat
par exemple en mathématiques le
raisonnement compte autant que le
résultat finalement les français sont
plutôt opposés à cette décision il ya un
sondage ifop 80% des français contre
cette suppression des notes
les français tiennent aux notes et assez
justement que ce soit visible tout de
suite sur la feuille
oui les français sont très friands de
notes de classement vous savez que par
exemple en judo on décline tout un tas
de ceinture de toutes les couleurs
france ô mais aussi par exemple au japon
il existe ou n'existe que la ceinture
blanche et ceinture noire on apprend où
on est m on pourrait imaginer ça aussi
pourquoi pas donc système scolaire
ça fera peut-être partie des des pistes
pour la refonte de l'école il y aura
beaucoup de discussions prochainement et
notamment dans l'académie de versailles
l'académie de versailles va participer
aux discussions nationales qui vont
s'engager à la concertation nationale il
y aura deux débats mi septembre
le recteur de l'académie viendra sur ce
plateau pour nous en parler demain en
direct à 18h vous en attendez quoi de
cette concertation nationale et des
concertations qui auront lieu dans
l'académie de versailles notamment vous
y participeraient aussi lève ses
partisans mais pas on n'est pas encore
invité mais je pense qu'au fond je pense
qu'on va l'être on a de bons bras pour
passer le message aux recteurs de voir
avec monsieur roy synosia pas de y'a pas
de soucis puis c'est la rentrée pour lui
et pour nous aussi donc voilà les choses
on se met en place je pense moi je crois
que c'est important nous on réclame
depuis depuis longtemps une loi
d'orientation et de programmation sur
l'école je pense que c'est important
qu'ils aient cette concertation il faut
qu'elle soit le plus large possible j'ai
l'impression que c'est avec ça que ça
vient doucement on sait que par exemple
sur les rythmes scolaires il est aussi
important de consulter les
professionnels du tourisme
voilà moi je pense qu'il faut que ce
soit une loi qui qui qui emmène
l'ensemble du corps social donc il faut
que la concertation soit large dure
longtemps qu'on prenne le temps enfin de
réformer l'école ce qu'on n'a pas fait
ces dernières années
vous avez évoqué les rythmes scolaires
justement c'est la question que nous
sommes allez vous poser aujourd'hui
faut-il modifier l le rythme scolaire
vos réponses modifier les rythmes
scolaires
ça dépend ce que vous entendez par
rythme scolaire 6 est supprimée le
samedi matin effectivement ça pourrait
être plus reposant pour eux parce que
c'est vrai que cinq jours se lever cinq
jours six jours de la semaine c'est
plutôt difficile
personnellement non je pense que c'est
c'est adapté à l'acier enfin oui ça ça
correspond au rythme des enfants pas de
moi j'ai pas de souci oui alors alors
plus précisément moi je trouve que
l'après midi un peu à l'allemande ce
serait parfait et jamais le samedi et
puis les gamins le mercredi que le matin
c'est bien aussi que le sport les choses
comme ça mais moins de vacances d'été
mais je sais que ça plaît pas mais c'est
que moi je trouve que cinq heures c'est
la bonne limite parce que plus tard
après ça ferait trop jeu si on finit
plus tard caddie et quelques 17 heures
après on en a vraiment marre du collège
et on n'a plus envie de travailler donc
cinq heures c'est bien et 8h30 c'est
bien aussi mais je pense qu'il faudrait
mettre peut-être un peu plus de
premières - d'éducation physique entre
autres et puis leur apprendre ce que
c'est que la peinture puisque apprendre
ce que c'est que la musique
voilà je crois qu'il faudrait un peu
éveillé en eux autre chose que
simplement d'orthographe et les matinées
rythme scolaire est ce que c'est
possible de terminer l'école aux
alentours de 15h 15h30 et de revenir à
une semaine de cinq jours également
oui je pense que la semaine de cinq
jours ça c'est très important enfin la
semaine de neuf demi-journées plus
exactement plus que la semaine de cinq
jours ça je pense que c'est
indispensable on a bien vu les ravages
que que ça a fait cette cette
suppression du samedi matin
moi je jeune femme nous la fcpe on est
on est pour la modification des rythmes
scolaires
même si on sait que ça va bouleverser
l'ensemble de la société c'est pas une
petite réforme c'est quelque chose sur
des enfants après 15h 15h30 si on perd
voilà il faut s'occuper des enfants et
si ce sont les 6e sont les villes qui
s'en occupe
ou les
les agglomérations etc il faut qu'ils
aient des moyens donc l'étape pas se
décharger sur sur d'autres de ses
responsabilités donc il faut un grand
service public d'éducation qui s'occupe
des enfants y compris après après la
classe pourquoi pas enfin ça pose tout
un tas de tout un tas de questions qu'on
va pas résoudre en deux mois et demi
quoi c'est vraiment important de prendre
le temps de réfléchir
mais le ski et ski pour moi et doit être
la base de la réflexion
c'est quand même les capacités
d'apprentissage des enfants et
annonçaient qu'elles sont limitées dans
la journée qu'un enfant peut parler huit
heures par jour à l'école et à prendre
vous savez que les lycéens sont à plus
de 35 heures nous on est aux 35 heures
lycéens sont à plus de 35 heures donc il
faut quand même être sérieux quoi
l'autre dossier majeur de cette rentrée
qui va occuper toutes les discussions
c'est forcément la formation des
enseignants faut-il revenir à des iufm
ou trouver une autre solution en tout
cas il ya déjà des mesures qui ont été
mises en place les enseignants sont déjà
au travail une attention est portée tout
particulièrement à ses stagiaires de
première année depuis la fin du mois
d'août l'académie de versailles a réuni
es les quelques 250 de professeur de
première année des yvelines c'est à
villepreux explications maxime le même
estelle épinards fait partie des 250 de
professeurs des écoles stagiaires qui
feront leur rentrée dans les yvelines le
4 septembre la jeune femme fraîchement
diplômée d'un master d'enseignement à
étudier dans l'académie de bordeaux où
elle a eu l'occasion de participer à une
expérience pilote enseigner une journée
par semaine dans une vraie classe malgré
cette préparation elle appréhende la
prise en main de sa classe de ce2 à
mantes la jolie
la semaine prochaine on n'a pas été
préparé à cela pendant
les stages puisqu'on arrivé en cours
d'année dans des classes qui avait déjà
un maître titulaire et un fonctionnement
en place donc ça ça va être un peu plus
nouveau donc oui c'est la seule petite
appréhension mais après je reste
confiante et je m'inquiète pas pour
l'aider à prendre ses fonctions le plus
sereinement possible
estelle a participé pendant cinq jours à
une période d'accueil au lycée
sonia-delaunay de villepreux
au programme présentation de diverses
problématiques auxquelles devront faire
face les enseignants les problématiques
qu'ils vont rencontrer au durant leur
carrière
la scolarisation des élèves handicapés
les élèves en difficulté les situations
d'enfants pour lesquels nous sommes
parfois obligés de faire des
signalements en direction de la justice
de la police pendant leur année de stage
les professeurs seront accompagnés par
un tuteur est un maître compagnon
ils participeront également à des
regroupements durant lesquels ils
pourront aborder des problèmes qu'ils
rencontrent au quotidien
à la fin de l'année la plupart de ses
professeurs seront titularisés comme
l'ont été l'ensemble des stagiaires
yvelinois de l'année scolaire précédente
ce dossier de la formation des
enseignants on voit que dans l'académie
de versailles a déjà des choses qui se
mettent en place on prête une attention
particulière aux stagiaires de première
année
il faut aller plus loin revenir un
système comme les iufm du côté de la
fcpe quelle serait la solution proposée
il faut il faut bien sûr aller plus loin
nous nous on pense on pense que feu
qu'enseigner est un métier qui s'apprend
comme beaucoup d'autres métiers comme
tous les autres métiers et
particulièrement celui là car est face à
une classe c'est pas évident bien sûr
on pense que les la solution pourquoi
pas de revenir à une à une année de
formation ou de spécifique au métier
d'enseignant ce serait une bonne chose
mais c'est que c'est sûr merci pierre
frelot de la fcpe soixante dix huit
présidents d'être venu sur ce plateau
un chiffre deux cent quatre-vingt seize
mille élèves du premier et second degré
établissements privés sous contrat
inclut vont faire leur rentrée demain
mardi 2 196 mills a fait quelques
collégiens lycéens et élèves de primaire
qui vont remettre leurs cartables merci
à vous et puis je vous rappelle un cette
information la visite de françois
hollande attrape ce matin dans le
collège youri-gagarine attrape il a
déclaré faire de l'éducation sa priorité
la priorité de son mandat
les images de cette visite seront arrête
de re découvrir d'ici la fin de cette
édition